THE GAME HE WAS GLAD IT GET CHAR
DUBE, ELECTS TO SHOT AND NEMETH
GOT A STICCG TEAM.
THIS IS THE INITIAL CHANCE BY GD
ZADOROV ARE BOTH GOING TO THE B]
SEAN MONAHAN, POWER
PASS BY LINDHOLM ALL OVER MARKÖ.
>
THERE YOU SEE SAMMY BLAIS IN THO
WILD.
>> AFTER THE MAKES A MOVE, STILE
BACKHAND, AND HE SCORES!CKS
THE SHOT.
THIS HAS PHYSICAL,.
REASON IS.nterpretati
THREE-ON-ONE CHANCE,
[ PERFECTLY OUT TO BRAD
RICHARDSON AND NO Horn Blaring ]
EVERYONE'S BACK HERE.
AND HE JUST COMES IN AND PUTS IT
TO THE OPEN NET.
NIKITA ZADOROV.
HE SKATES IN, ZADOROV LUCIC, BA.
>> Cassie: THESE ARE
MARKSTRÖM MADE THE SAVE,
REBOUND! AND
THEN KIND OF BOUNCES AROUND. TH,
KYLINGTON OUT OF THEKAEL BACKLUH
A CHANCE AND THEN WITH KYLINGTON
OUT OF THE BOX IT CREATES AeeriE
SENSE FOR THE NEW YORK RANGERS ,
A PASS IN UP TO
THIS LINE.
MA
[ Horn Blaring ]
[ Cheerinin OFF.
IT GOES RIGHT OFF THE STICK OF
NEMETH AND Blaring ]
[ Cheering ]
OUTSIDE THE